and get 2 months free.
>> Laura: FOX NEWS IS
REPORTING THAT WE ARE HOURS AWAY
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP A D
CLASSIFYING AND RELEASING THAT
FURIOUSLY TRYING TO PREVENT THE
TOMORROW, IT WILL BE RELEASED.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION IS
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN DON
ARE A VERY BRAVE PERSON.
YOU ARE JUST THE THIRD
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKER TO COME ON
THIS SHOW SINCE IT BEGAN THREE
MONTHS AGO.
YOU ARE NOW A MEMBER OF AN ELITE
CLUB.
>> LET'S MAKE IT A WEEKLY THING.
>> Laura: IT'S GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
TELL US ABOUT THIS MEMO AND MY
FIRST QUESTION IS WHY HAVEN'T
YOU GONE TO READ THE MEMO?
>> I WAS ABOUT TO DO SO TUESDAY
IT BECAUSE IF I DO, I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
I'M ON THE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND I DO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION VIRTUALLY EVERY
WEEK, OFTEN EVERY DAY AND I KNOW
THAT I CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BECOME
>> Laura: ALL OF THESE
CONGRESSMEN HAVE BEEN ALL OVER
TELEVISION, THEY ARE NOT TALKING
HAVE TRANSPARENCY.
CONGRESSIONAL ETHICAL
OBLIGATIONS?
SEEMS LIKE WILLFUL BLINDNESS TO
THE VIEWERS.
>> I DON'T THINK SO AT ALL, I
KNOW THIS IS COMING OUT AND WE
WILL REVIEW IT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE WE ARE IN A HIGHLY
PARTISAN, VERY CHARGED
ENVIRONMENT, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS BOTH OF THEM GOING
HAVE THEIR MEMO COME UP WITH
THEM BOTH OUT THERE, LET THE
PUBLIC JUDGE EXACTLY WHAT THIS
THE CIA DIRECTOR SAID THAT HE
FULLY ANTICIPATES THAT RUSSIA
WILL INTERFERE IN THE 2018
ELECTIONS WHICH ARE COMING UP
NEXT MONTH IN MARCH.
ALMOST NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE
ABOUT PROTECTING OUR ELECTION
PROCESS.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> Laura: I UNDERSTAND THAT
LATELY.
TO DO WITH THE MEMO?
>> THE MEMO ITSELF SPEAKS TO
ANOTHER PART OF THE PROBLEM THAT
CONFRONTS US AND THAT IS --
>> Laura: COME ON, THE MEMO
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA COLLUSION, I BET MY
BOTTOM DOLLAR IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH COLLUSION.
WHEN IT DOES HAVE TO DO WITH IS
HOW A FISA APPLICATION WAS
DRAFTED AND ON WHAT IT WAS BASED
DRAFTED AND ON WHAT IT WAS BASE
BASED.
IF IT WAS BASED ON OPPOSITION
RESEARCH, THAT SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN DONE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE QUITE
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
>> ALLOW ME TO GO BACK TO THE
POINT I MADE A MOMENT AGO.
WE ARE IN A VERY CHARGED, HIGHLY
AROUND THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES ARE ACTING PROPERLY
UNDER THE RESTRICTIONS AND THE
>> Laura: ARE WE GOING TO FIND
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE IS THE REPUBLICAN REPORT,
DEMOCRAT REPORT >> Laura: I'M
FINE WITH THAT.
>> PUT THEM ON THE TABLE, AND
LET'S GET THE INFORMATION OUT
THE MEMO TONIGHT.
>> TOMORROW MORNING IT WILL BE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES ARE ABLE
TO PROTECT US.
BOTH OF THOSE MEMOS ON THE
TABLE, AND A HEARING, LET'S GET
THE MEMOS OUT THERE.
>> Laura: WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IT.
NUMBER THREE, TELL YOUR